[Music]
[Applause]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and
welcome to the unboxing
of the samsung galaxy note
fe fan edition i don't know that's what
they were going to call it the fan
edition but uh this is a revival
basically a refurbished galaxy note 7
but with no seven anywhere on the
packaging you can also see a little
heart on the front there for fans i
guess uh let's go ahead and open it up
and see what's different uh as far as we
know specs have not changed
so there you go right up at the top
is the note 7 fan edition the stylus of
course still there
[Music]
get your
earbuds here that's a good sign
and your power adapter and usb type-c
cable that's all the same as it was with
the note 7. actually the phone itself
once you get the stickers and everything
off
are exactly the same as the note 7 same
specs same software
just with a slightly smaller battery you
can see it says note fan edition right
there that's the biggest physical change
and that's uh
that's pretty much it uh
maybe we can take some questions all
right can we get a logitech mx master 2s
review
okay
uh so i actually have the logitech mx
master 2s this gray here is the 2s
this dark navy gold is the mx master
uh there's actually also not that much
of a difference here you can see up at
the front on the button itself
uh it says logi
instead of the entire logitech name
that's actually the biggest physical
difference there's no usb type-c or any
different connector or anything same
capabilities just a better battery life
and higher dpi and a new color
so that's uh
that's also it for that i think we'll
just we'll just take a lot more
questions how did you learn to use final
cut pro did you just practice with the
software or did someone teach you okay
so funny story actually about the time
that i first started using final cut pro
when i was first starting to learn video
editing it was with camtasia studio and
i used that because a lot of my videos
at that time were screencasts and that
was actually a software used for
recording your screen and then editing
that screencast so i had a bunch of
features for like highlighting your
mouse and following the cursor around
the screen stuff like that i switched
from that to adobe premiere and i
learned a lot in the adobe world in the
premiere and after effects and photoshop
world all because of that switch but
then i switched from a pc to a mac and
then we got to the kobe interview so we
did this interview and i say we because
it was a collaboration actually between
me doing the actual interview with kobe
and a behind-the-scenes video and a lot
of help setting that up for my buddies
austin and john those two guys are both
mac users who used final cut pro and
swore by it and will constantly try to
get me to switch to final cut pro that
was pretty stubborn i was like no i'm
i'm doing pretty well with adobe
premiere thank you very much but we're
editing our videos right i'm editing the
interview i'm cutting between the
multiple cameras in premiere they're
editing the behind the scenes in final
cut pro on their macs i hit export they
hit export
i'm still exporting and john's video his
behind the scenes finishes exporting and
then he watches it back and then catches
a mistake and something he wants to fix
he goes back into the editing fixes that
mistake and then re-exports the entire
thing again and uploads it and i'm still
at like 30 percent done exporting from
premiere it was at that moment that i
knew i had to give final cut pro a shot
and that's when i switched honestly
final cut pro is that much faster on
macs because of a bunch of things
besides just optimization and quick sync
uh it's kind of a no-brainer for me at
this point i could always go back to
windows and back to premiere if i wanted
to but i've learned all my keyboard
shortcuts and i am self-taught at a lot
of what i do in these editing apps so
it's not really a huge deal since you
don't use a phone case how many phones
have you actually broken slash damage
like crack the screen etc okay i've only
actually in my lifetime of reviewing
phones crack the screen on one but i
have dropped two and damaged them the
most recent one i actually damaged was
this one plus five i dropped my one plus
five getting out of the car at practice
like two days before i was gonna shoot
my review uh put a skin over it it was
fine but the last phone i actually broke
the screen of was the second gen moto x
when i was like a sophomore in college
dropped it like literally face down on
the sidewalk that actually broke it but
honestly for the amount of time i've
been using phones in my lifetime that's
a pretty decent record of like two in
seven years i think okay this one's in
all caps why do you always have
bluetooth and location services on all
the time honestly it's basically just
for the convenience i have no problem
with battery life as it is you can turn
them off to save battery life but i like
walking up to my car and sitting down in
the driver's seat and the music is
already playing for my phone just
because bluetooth paired that fast every
time i want to connect to bluetooth
headphones it's just one button and
they're connected and we go same thing
with speakers if i want to go into maps
i don't have to turn on location
services wait for it to connect get gps
and then go i kind of just go what's
your typing speed
[Applause]
if you happen to live in the world of
game of thrones whom would you kill
first
honestly i've never seen an episode of
game of thrones in my life so i'm
probably missing out i'm not the best
person to answer this question
i mostly watch a lot more youtube videos
than tv shows when shooting videos do
you draw any inspiration from filmmakers
or photographers which ones influence
your aesthetic uh really interesting
question actually i'd like to say i'm
building my own style and a lot of of
course inspiration comes from various
places mostly actually also in the
youtube world in the online world i
don't watch that many movies but you
could say a little bit of it comes from
other tech youtubers other skitch sketch
sketch makers but i do want to link to a
video that i think is amazing coming
from a quote from ira glass it's an
animation built around something he said
often which is you kind of have your own
taste and people don't tell us to
beginners very much but you don't really
have the most confidence in your early
work because you have this really nice
taste and you don't think your early
work lives up to that taste but you just
have to keep working at what you do over
and over again and longer and longer so
you can build up to that taste and
actually satisfy your own crazy what you
want to be so i'm linked that below i
think it's really good and if you're
into creative stuff at all or if you
want to be a youtuber and make stuff you
should watch it can you do a review on
the hasselblad okay so those of you who
have been following me for the past a
little bit on like twitter or instagram
know that i recently got or have been
using the hasselblad x1d it's insane in
a lot of ways and i understand why you'd
want a review of it but i'd almost feel
bad reviewing it because the use that i
have for this camera is definitely not
the use of the people who would be
watching a review of this camera you
know what i mean this is a really
compact but still really really premium
handheld medium format sensor it's a 50
megapixel sensor in this camera it does
incredible things it's sharp edge to
edge with the glass that comes with it
and i will not be using it to shoot ads
or billboards or portraits i'm using it
to shoot like photos of smartphones and
tablets and handheld devices for twitter
and instagram and i'll probably do some
other stuff like just random photos of
things i see for wallpaper type
materials i started a flickr account
again if you want the high resolution
50 megapixel versions of these images
but i almost feel bad reviewing it in a
way that's kind of like not something
anyone can take advantage of maybe i'll
do a highlight of it maybe it'll be in
dope tech maybe i'll just show you guys
what i'm doing with it and why it's so
awesome because i really do think it's
awesome but yeah i probably won't review
the hasselblad so i'm gonna stop it
right there as far as questions that i
answer but i'm actually going to turn
this around i've done these q and a's
for a while now and i want to end it by
turning around a question for you guys
and i'm going to bring it from something
i tweeted recently what would you think
since everyone's making smartphones now
what would you think if tesla made a
smartphone
what if
what would it be into what would you
like about it what would you expect to
see from a tesla smartphone i mean red's
making a smartphone now why not right
let me know what you think
thanks for watching
talk to you guys in the next one
peace
[Music]